hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen mod
vorstellung heute werde ich euch den
world download vorstellen mit dem ihr
euch welten von anderen servern die ihr
multiplayer bespielt ganz einfach
runterladen könnt da gibt es eine nette
funktion dann könnt ihr diese welten bei
euch im singleplayer modus spielen also
ganz einfach hört sich ganz einfach an
ist auch total einfach und ich werde ich
jetzt im laufe des videos mal ganz ganz
ganz ganz ganz ganz schnell zeigen wie
das funktioniert viel spaß und hier
befinden wir uns nun auch in der
theaterwelt beziehungsweise in der
früheren zuger welt vom den anc und mir
wir in der letzten folge von dem let's
play together wahrscheinlich schon
mitbekommen habt hat den er sich eine
teekanne gebaut und hat hier ein
bisschen was in der luft gesprengt aber
das hat er alles in der letzten folge
gesehen was da los war
aber das soll jetzt aber aber aber ob
aber aber aber nein egal
das soll jetzt nicht das thema sein denn
wir wollen uns um den mod körper und
beziehungsweise die modifikation kommt
darauf an
also wenn ihr auf einem server seid was
ich gerade bin ich kann hier schreiben
hallo segeberg hat auf dem server ist
ihr drückt einfach escape und geht nicht
auf verbindung trennen sondern click
above to watch the world's klick jetzt
seht ihr unten links moment ich kannte
das mal ganz kurz optionen chat
einstellungen können wir ganz gut zu
machen zwtl sagt der download wurde
gestartet das heißt genau an dieser
stelle hier wo ich den download
gestartet habe
geht's los nun beginnt die zeit wo ihr
hier rumlaufen müsst und teilt er läuft
halt einfach so ein bisschen rum und
alle orte wo ihr jetzt so rumlaufen und
wo die tanks quasi geladen werden zum
beispiel da hinten jetzt gerade alles
neu geladen sich gerade all das sowohl
jetzt rum läuft wird quasi in den
download mit reingepackt das heißt dass
da ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz hinten
wird nicht mit reingepackt er ist dann
einfach so eine komische grenze aber das
zeige ich euch einfach gleich wenn ich
ein bisschen rum gelaufen bin
das heißt ich laufe jetzt ein bisschen
ich hab eisen gebunden
so ich bin jetzt hier ein wenig herum
geflogen bin ein bisschen rumgelaufen
ich habe die tanks laden lassen da hin
zum beispiel wenn ich ein bisschen
wissen warum wo ist der dschungel naja
egal wenn ich durch den dschungel ein
bisschen gegangen sollte auch mit dem
download drin sein und ihr halt weiter
habe ich auch alles laden lassen da
hinten bin ich extra nicht gegangen weil
ich euch dass da hinten zeigen wollte
also ich bin jetzt auf dem baum von
topshop media glaube ich ja auf dem haus
von dem das heißt wir gehen jetzt nicht
in den chat wir gehen jetzt wieder in
skate menüs klicken auf stop download da
steht ihr sailing world data und dann
steht der download shop safety single
player world kontrapunkt minecraft ja
genau das ist die server ip aber ihr
braucht gar nicht versuchen darauf zu
knacken weil da wild bist raus ist also
ihr gibt nun wieder escape verbindung
trennen einzelnen spieler dann ein
findet ihr hier kontrapunkt minecraft
puncto hier sind ein paar andere welten
von mir da klickt ihr einfach drauf und
ihr habt da da ziemlich schnell die welt
hier drin
das heißt die aktion hier den kompletten
bereich da drin so mache ich das hält
mittlerweile immer mit nitro wählten die
ich mir dann einfach so runterziehen
stadt dass ich die irgendwie mir auf den
desktop ziehen muss von der website von
denen und hier das wollte ich euch ja
zeigen
hier wurde noch alles mit gezogen das
heißt da der platz wo basti zum beispiel
sand abgebaut hat wird als nur mit
rübergenommen hier die wüste auch noch
ein teil
und hier ist der tank dann zu ende
gewesen also hier wird nicht mehr über
kopiert das heißt genau diese grenze
hier war da sonst eigentlich nicht
und hier war dann halt auch noch krank
sind dann hier ist dann wahrscheinlich
auch noch mehr hier um die ecke weil ich
dorthin geflogen bin
als wirklich nur da kommt der komplette
bereich dahinten den da habe ich
umflogen jahr genau hier ist jetzt
einfach alles abgeschnitten sieht das
natürlich nicht so schön aus der center
noch ein paar fehler hier vorhanden zum
beispiel beim wasser weil es einfach so
abgeschnitten wurde kann man dann
natürlich so ein bisschen ausbessern
jetzt immer noch behindert ist egal es
geht halt darum wenn ihr auf einem
großen server seite von irgendwelchen
minecraft kann dann jeder einfach drauf
und wenn ihr die welt mit euch
runterziehen wenn ihr wenn die wellen
bla bla bla bla bla
wenn es die welt nicht zum download gibt
dann könnt ihr euch die einfach mit
dieser modifikation runterladen aber ich
würde sie nicht zum download anbieten
weil er dann bestimmt irgendwann
schwierigkeiten wegen copyright und so
weiter bekommt also einfach nur für euch
selber wenn ihr einen teil
tolle server welt seht dann downloaded
euch die einfach und ja das war es dann
auch eigentlich schon mit dieser mod
vorstellung wie gesagt vorsichtig sein
wenn ihr die dann irgendwo anders
hochladen also wirklich nur von eigenen
gebrauch nutz und dann ist das
eigentlich ganz gut
ja das war es jetzt auch schon wieder
mit diesem video meine lieben freunde
wie immer bitte vergesst nicht das video
zu bewerten wenn jetzt total toll fand
dann bitte einen daumen hoch geben und
wenn ihr er sagte als nicht so mein fall
dann daumen runter geben und was ich
auch noch sagen wollte ist wer jetzt
bestimmt schon aus den kommentaren
entnommen oder ihr habt vielleicht schon
in anderen videos von mir gesehen oder
halt weil es einfach in der beschreibung
stand ihr könnt mir nun immer euren
minecraft skin mit dem ihr in minecraft
in game spielt also zb tadeusz lp hat
die minecraft namen tadeusz mmc dann
schreibt ihr mir einfach in die
kommentare und eventuell spiele ich bei
der nächsten vorstellung von einem
texture pack einzieht einer mod oder
einem update oder so weiter vielleicht
spiele ich da mit eurem skin das heißt
eine chance für euch mainz kind zu sehen
und ja das war es auch erst mal von
meiner stelle ich würde mich auf jeden
fall über den domhof freuen und wir
sehen uns dann beim nächsten mal